let Omega be the complex number cosine
of 2 pi over 3 plus I sine of 2 PI over
3
then the number of distinct complex
numbers Z satisfying where this
determinant equaling 0 so this have this
3 by 3 determinant equaling 0 so let's
just evaluate this determinant and see
if we can solve for Z or figure out how
many complex numbers Z that we get
satisfying this what's essentially an
equation so let's evaluate the
determinant so if we start with this
term up here if we start with this term
right here it's going to be this term
times the determinant of this sub 2 by 2
matrix so it's going to be Z plus 1 Z
plus 1 times Z plus 1 times Z plus Omega
squared times Z plus Omega Z plus Omega
squared times Z plus Omega minus 1 minus
1 so this is the determinant of the sub
of the sub 2 by 2 matrix right over here
the sub 2 by 2 determinant and that's
the Z plus 1 and then we're going to we
have to swap signs we go here we want to
put a negative sign out front you have
kind of that checkerboard pattern when
you evaluate determinants so minus Omega
times you block out that row that column
so it's Omega the sub the sub determiner
is Omega times Z plus Omega let me just
multiply that out right now so that's Z
Omega plus Omega squared minus Omega
squared times 1 so minus Omega squared
so that's pretty neat we already got
something that simplifies a little bit
and then we have to worry about this
Omega squared so it's going to be plus
plus Omega squared times Omega times 1
Omega times 1 is Omega minus Omega
squared times Z plus Omega so minus
Omega squared Z Omega squared Z minus
Omega to the fourth minus Omega to the
fourth and remember this whole
expression needs to be equal to 0 this
whole thing needs to be equal to 0 now
let's see if we can
see if we can simplify this thing a
little bit so let me first multiply
these two guys in here so Z times Z is Z
squared z times Omega is Z Omega Omega
squared times Z is is Omega squared Z
and then Omega squared times Omega is
omega to the third power plus Omega to
the third power and then we have this
minus 1 here and then all of that's
going to be multiplied by Z plus 1 let
me just continue with this blue part
since we're already focused here so this
is going to be Z times all of this so
it's going to be Z to the third power
plus Z squared Omega plus Omega squared
Z squared plus Omega to the third Z
minus Z I just multiplied Z times all of
this and then plus 1 times all of this
so Plus this thing again Z squared plus
Z Omega plus Omega squared Z plus Omega
to the third minus -1 and then let's
simplify this over here so then green
these cancelled out so we're just left
with I'll do the same green negative
Omega times Z Omega so it's minus Z
Omega squared and then over here in
magenta here in magenta we have plus
plus Omega to the third power Omega to
the third power minus Omega to the third
Z Omega to the third Z right let me be
careful that would be Omega Omega to the
fourth don't make it Omega squared times
Omega squared is Omega to the fourth
Omega to the fourth Z and then Omega
squared times Omega to the fourth is
Omega to the 6 and we have a negative
sign so negative Omega to the sixth and
of course this whole thing needs to be
equal to zero now there's some there's
probably well let's see if we can
simplify this so let's just group the
terms the different powers of Z so we
have a Z to the third here so we have a
Z to the
third Z to the third and that is the
only Z to the third that we have and
then let's group let's group the Z
squared terms so this is a Z squared
term this is a Z squared term that's a Z
squared term and then we don't have
anymore
Z squared terms and so the coefficients
this is going to be the same thing as
Omega squared that's this one right over
here plus Omega plus Omega plus one plus
one times times Z squared so we've taken
care of everything that I've underlined
in pink over here now let's wonder it
worried about the Z terms the Z terms
I'll do it in this color so this is a Z
term we're just multiplying times Z this
is a Z term this is a Z term that is
also a Z term and then do we have any
other Z term so this is a Z term right
over here in fact these two cancel out
you have negative Z Omega squared
positive Z Omega squared so this and
this cancel out and so our only is Z
terms are these three over here so we
have plus Omega to the third and then we
have plus Omega to the third oh let me
this color is too close plus Omega to
the third and then our next Z is minus
one but that we actually have this Omega
here so plus Omega minus one I was
getting confused because this white is
so close to this pink so it's Omega the
third Omega to the third minus one plus
Omega times Z and then oh we can't
forget this we have this term over here
Omega to the fourth times Z Omega to the
fourth times Z so we have minus 1 right
Omega to the third Z then we have minus
1z then we have then we have plus Omega
Z and then we have negative Omega to the
fourth Z so I'll just put it out here
I'm not doing it a nice descending power
order but I don't want to have to
rewrite all of this so then we took care
of all of the Z terms and then what we
have left is just what we can kind of
view the constant terms from
point of view so we have Omega squared
Omega so plus Omega cubed actually we
have two Omega cubed we have an Omega
cubed here and Omega cubed there we've
taken care of those and then we have
minus Omega to the 6 and then we have
minus 1 and all of this needs to equal 0
now this look might look pretty daunting
especially when Omega looks like this
fairly complex it well it isn't a
complex expression but maybe or probably
it popped into your mind that this can
also be expressed as an exponential
using Euler's formula we know that e we
know that e to the I theta is equal to
cosine of theta plus I sine of theta so
this so Omega can be rewritten as Omega
is the exact same thing as e to the 2 pi
to the 2 pi over 3 I
that's what Omega is now what is what is
and what is e to the 2 PI over 3 I we
can evaluate that here it's cosine 2 pi
over 3 and we can get our unit circle
out 2 PI over 3 corresponds to 120
degrees so let me get my unit circle out
just so we can figure out what the
values are and the reason why I'm doing
this I'm actually going to evaluate it
here just to get a number here but the
reason I'm doing this it becomes much
much easier to take the powers of e to
the 2 pi over 3 I then to take the
powers of this thing over here but if we
take the unit circle if we're at 120
degrees on the unit circle like this
this is 2 pi this is 2 PI over 3 then we
have a situation this angle over here is
going to be 60 degrees and so our height
is going to be square root of 3 over 2
and where our x-coordinate is going to
be negative 1/2 so this is going to be
equal to negative 1/2
cosine of 2 pi over 3 is negative 1/2
and then our sine of 2 pi over 3 square
root of 3 over 2 but that's being
multiplied by an eye so plus square root
of 3 over 2i so that is omega now let's
think about Omega squared Omega square
it is going to be this raised to the
second power so it's e to the we just
multiply it by 2 e to the 4 PI over 3 I
we just multiplied this by 2 so it's
equivalent to 240 degrees so it's
equivalent to this right over here so
let me write it this is the same thing
as cosine of 4 PI over 3 plus I sine of
4 PI over 3 and here our x-coordinate is
going to be the same it's going to be
negative 1/2 so this is equal to
negative 1/2 and our y-coordinate is
negative square root of 3 over 2 minus
square root of 3 over 2i now let's think
of Omega to the third power Omega to the
third power is equal to e to the 2 pi I
2 pi I which is equal to cosine of 2 pi
plus I sine of 2 pi well sine of 2 pi is
just 0 cosine of 2 pi is equal to is
equal to 1 then we go to Omega to the
fourth power because we that also shows
up in these expressions so we have Omega
to the fourth power is equal to if we
just multiply it times 4 it's e to the 8
PI 8 PI over 3 I or that's equivalent to
2 that's 8 PI over 3 is equivalent to so
this was this was 2 PI over 3 this is 4
PI over 3 this is essentially 6 PI over
3 and then 8 PI over 3 becomes is
essentially the same angle is
essentially the same angle as 2 PI over
3
so its value is going to be the same
negative 1/2 plus square root of 3 over
2i
and then we don't have a go to the 5th
but we do have an Omega to the sixth
here so let's just figure that out Omega
to the sixth well that's just Omega
cubed squared and Omega cubed is 1 so
it's just going to be 1 squared or it's
also going to be 1 now with that out of
the way let's see what these things
simplify to or hopefully they simplify
to something so this expression right
here Omega squared we have I'll write it
up here we have negative 1/2 minus
square root of 3 over 2i that's Omega
squared
then we have plus Omega Omega is right
here negative 1/2 plus square root of 3
over 2i and then we have a plus 1 so the
negative square root of 3 over 2i and
the positive square root of 3 over 2i
cancel out negative 1/2 minus 1/2 is
negative 1 plus 1 those cancel out so
this whole expression comes out to be 0
so we can ignore this is going to be 0
no matter what now let's look at this
over here this is Omega cubed Omega
cubed we know is 1 plus Omega which is
so I should write minus 1/2 plus square
root of 3 over 2i minus 1 minus Omega to
the fourth minus Omega to the fourth is
the same thing as Omega Omega to the
fourth is the same thing as Omega so you
have Omega minus something that's the
same thing as itself those are going to
cancel out
Omega cubed is 1 so the 1 and the 1 are
going to cancel out so this is also
equal to 0 so this term I think I see a
pattern here and then finally let's look
at these characters over here 2 times
Omega cubed this is just going to be a 2
here minus Omega to the 6 well that's
just minus 1 and then you have a minus 1
so this is 2 minus 1 minus 1 this is
also equal to 0 so that whole
determinant that whole equation has
simplified to Z to the third power is
equal to 0 and the only number that when
they take it to the 3rd power real or
complex or anything is going to be 0 z
equals 0 is the only solution but
they're not asking us that they're
asking the number of distinct complex
numbers Z satisfying this so Z equals 0
is the only one that satisfies this so
the number of complex numbers satisfying
it is 1